Tom knew to Hollywood this is all brand
new yeah while I've watched your show so
much I feel like I know you know this is
surreal to me this is my life has
flipped upside down in the last six
weeks it's exactly because mark you had
this when you know you made it big you
went to Hollywood and I mean it's been
kind of documented in Entourage
but what advice would you have for Tom
papa
I'm the last person you should ask for a
girl but you've never been to jail have
you there is a complete role reversal
see I went to jail before I had a career
so he's going to go to jail at some
point during your career yeah
don't take any advice for me the first
check I got I ran to the Mercedes dealer
I bought a car I didn't have money for
registration or insurance the police
told the vehicle because I was driving
without insurance so you don't want any
advice for me ladies the move get a
jacuzzi I just met all your brothers
bring the boys the county license hey
you got an excuse me the password pardon
oh I will have some done for me hold on
there I got four kids I could yelled at
and I did tell me how much they hate me
they give me a daddy I love you the best
dad ever Father's Day card which is nice
right then that works that's a beautiful
thing but go have some fun good looking
guy that's terrible advice but I hear
you where Norton here if you'd like to
see even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe
Auto free world but I know what I do in
that situation